22 year old daniel van heist is
described by those who knew him best as
the kind of soul you would ever meet
neighbors of his family in the small
town of verona are echoing that
statement as they grieve his sudden
death
every village has that one kid that will
go above and beyond to help anybody or
anything
and on that day that this incident
happened we lost that child
adam mori is a neighbor of the van heist
family and says daniel was always
helping others on one occasion mori says
daniel helped his wife after she
collapsed with heat stroke in front of
their family home he ran it with a
bottle of water and helped her and
stayed with her until i got back and
stories just like maurice have poured
onto social media in the form of
tributes to remember the young man who
was passionate about his job as an
arborist i ran a small tree service for
years
and i know how dangerous that equipment
is and it's it's just sad that it
happened the way it did
van heist was working with his employer
eco tree care on a contract with the
city of oshawa to remove ash trees
officials say just before 9 a.m
wednesday morning a piece of heavy
equipment killed an employee later
identified as van heist those who work
at the verona run family business did a
climb friday morning to honor their
fallen colleague
a gofundme site was set up by a family
member and local business owner and in
only eight hours the campaign reached 13
thousand dollars the family is now
asking anyone who would like to make a
donation to do so in person at the bank
of montreal in verona as well as at the
food less traveled grocery store an
investigation into what exactly caused
van gaal's death is ongoing as his
family begins to make funeral
arrangements yet to be announced